- But even the research here,
they're monkeying
around with bird flu
and all these different flues
that are very contagious,
and they're like saying,
"Well, it's really deadly,
but it's not aerosolized.
Let's try to make
it aerosolized.
Let's try to adapt
this deadly virus
that doesn't spread very easily,
let's see if we can
make it spread easier."
It's a death wish.
(dramatic music)
- I'm Dave Rubin,
and joining me today
from Washington DC
is the just reelected senator
from the great state
of Kentucky, Rand Paul.
Welcome to the,
as you called it,
the Dungeon Rubin Report.
- Yeah.
Glad to be with you.
(Dave laughs)
- All right, so when
we booked this trip,
we knew we were gonna do
something post-election.
We thought there was gonna
be some sort of a red wave,
thought you guys were gonna
be in charge of the Senate.
- Can we pretend like we're
still before the election
and there still is the
possibility of a red wave?
- Did not work out that way.
How you feeling?
- You know, with
my race, very good.
We got the highest
percentage we've ever gotten.
I got about 62%.
In most of our rural counties,
we got between 70 and 80%.
We had 10 counties,
we got more than
85% of the vote,
10 counties more than 80%,
probably all together,
about 50 counties,
more than 70% of the vote.
So that kind of
shows a little bit
of what's going on nationally.
That was from rural counties.
We do very well
in rural America,
not so well in urban America.
So we have two
cities in Kentucky,
Louisville and Lexington,
that are of any kind
of significant size,
we lose those 60/40.
But I think that's
part of the answer to,
you know, how we do
around the country.
You see, we win the geography,
we just don't win the
population necessarily.
- How long do you
think that can hold,
when people look at the map
and they see basically an
80 to 90% seemingly red map,
and then they see the population
centers that are blue,
the tension between
those two areas?
- Well, something's gotta give,
but we're basically just
about evenly divided.
I mean, it's hard to believe
you can have an
election in Georgia
and there's an
almost even amount.
I mean, almost exactly
even amount of people
on either side of the divide.
And I think people are voting
more just which tribe
they think they belong to.
People say, "Oh, it's
about candidate quality."
Well, frankly, Dr. Oz
is a great candidate.
I've seen him campaign.
He's a great retail campaigner.
He's on daytime TV, you know,
for goodness for
a decade or more,
He's very good with people
and very likable,
very intelligent,
can answer all the questions.
And so, I don't
think he was defeated
'cause he wasn't
quality of candidate,
I think it's that we're in
sort of these separate camps,
and they are different camps.
But frankly, it's interesting
when I meet people,
almost anybody who's
working is in our camp.
I mean, so it's interesting.
You go into a machine shop
and 10 guys have
grease on their hands,
they're as Republican
as you come.
And they're not very considerate
of people who don't work.
In fact, they're disdainful
But we also have a labor
force participation
where 38% of our
country doesn't work.
So, that's a huge
block of voters there.
There's also a huge block
of government voters.
In fact, I think the
87,000 IRS agents
is more about politics than
it is about harassing us.
Sure, they'll harass
us. That's a given.
And I don't want them.
But I think it's really about
87,000 more voters in Virginia.
Maybe not all of them-
- Oh, wow!
- in Virginia,
but a lot of them would
be in Northern Virginia,
that could tip the balance.
- So literally,
just moving people
from wherever to Virginia
just to take this job
because it's so close.
- Well, and also,
they're also employed for
a long time for government,
there's a tendency to say,
well, you know, deficit's
kind of a problem,
but then again, they
pay me really well.
So, you see how government
workers gradually
kinda shift over to
the Democrat party,
and most of the three counties,
you know, just on the other
side of the Potomac River
are very Democrat,
but they're all federal
government workers.
If you grow the
federal government,
you make it harder for a
Republican to win Virginia.
- Is that your
biggest frustration,
as probably the most libertarian
senator that we have,
that people just, in
the end of the day,
despite candidate
quality or anything else,
they kinda just want
more stuff, sadly?
- Well, it is, and I
talk about it a lot.
You know, when I talk to folks
at home around the country,
it's that what we're
offering is intangible.
We're offering the opportunity,
we're offering freedom,
the allure of what
comes with it,
one that you're left alone to do
whatever the heck you wanna do,
but also that great
prosperity comes with freedom.
But it's an intangible,
it's not a concrete.
The other side's offering
you a cell phone.
You want a cell phone,
you want the government
to buy you a cell phone,
to pay for your college,
you want the government to pay
for your housing and your food.
And so, they're
offering something.
And it's the allure of
something for nothing.
And the people working for
it are frustrated by it.
The people receiving
are are like,
yeah, that's not too bad.
Maybe I could use more.
Maybe I could have,
what about universal
basic income, you know?
- So if if things had gone
a little bit differently
and the senate had broke red,
would you be licking
your chops right now,
figuring out what
to do with Fauci,
and figuring out what-
- We still are gonna try?
It's obviously not ideal
but I'm gonna try hard to
convince the Democrats.
I don't know if you
read Nicholas Wade's
article in Medium.
This came out about a year ago
and it was the article
that awoke everybody
I hadn't even paid
much attention
to the lab leak until
I read his article.
It's like 40, 50 page article.
No one would touch it.
None of the mainstream
media would print.
He printed it on Medium,
which is a self publication
but it's incredibly well done.
He's written for nature, science
New York Times science writer.
And he writes this and
it's just an amazing reveal
of how the science points
towards this coming
from the lab and that
there has been a coverup.
So anyway, I sent that
article to leading Democrats
on the Homeland Security
that has the oversight
to investigate this
with the hope that maybe
one of them will read
it and go, my God,
we should investigate this
or this could happen again.
- Where does that
hope stand right now?
I mean, does anyone who
you send them these things,
does anyone care?
- I've tried for
two years to get
any kind of hearing and
have not had any luck.
But I think some of it is,
it became very public, the
squabble with Dr. Fauci.
And he became the
paragon of government.
And they, the Democrats
love government.
So they don't want anyone
attacking government.
But the really, the look
into the virus's origins
isn't an attack of Biden.
In fact, most of this happened
under the Trump
administration, frankly,
and under the maybe
Obama administration.
But letting go of
gain of function,
letting gain of function
research get started again,
really, there was a pause
and I think they were
disobeying the pause
but then really it happened
under the Trump administration.
I don't think Trump had
any idea what was going on
but it did happen during
his administration.
So it really isn't
pointing fingers
at one president or the other.
It's really about getting
to the bottom of this
so this doesn't happen again.
- So even if you had the Senate
and you were in charge
of the committee
that was, you know,
putting Fauci out there
and dealing with all of that,
it's not like much
happens after, right.
I think that's one of the things
people are always
confused about.
Like, we have these hearings
then does anything
ever actually come,
- I think people
want some, you know
people at the Trump rallies
say, lock them up, you know.
They want somebody locked up.
And frankly, if you
lie to Congress,
if you're a Republican
they do lock you up.
If you're a Democrat,
they ignore you.
But I don't have any,
I guess naive hopes,
that that would happen.
If you did lie,
and if Fauci lied,
yes you should go to jail.
But they control the
DOJ. And so, I see that.
My hope is still this, even
in the minority in the Senate,
my hope is to win the argument,
convince the public and
then do something about it.
And that doesn't
mean necessarily
someone goes to jail.
What it means is that
we regulate gain of
function research.
Our tax dollars number one,
shouldn't go to Wuhan, China.
Period.
Even if they're, you know,
just trying to
discover a penicillin,
I wouldn't send them
the money to do it
'cause I don't trust them.
And we don't have any money.
We're borrowing it from
them to send it to them.
So, it doesn't make any sense.
So, I wouldn't send any money
to most foreign
countries for research.
Let's do some research here.
But even the research here,
they're monkeying
around with bird flu
and all these different flues
that are very contagious
and they're like saying,
well it's really deadly
but it's not aerosolized.
Let's try to make
it aerosolized.
Let's try to adapt
this deadly virus
that doesn't spread very easily.
Let's see if we can
make it spread easier.
It's a death wish.
So, we did have one
subcommittee hearing
and I had three
scientists come in.
They're not partisans
I don't even know they're
a political persuasion.
In fact, I think some
of them lean Democrat,
one from Rutgers, one from MIT
and one who's a
tech entrepreneur.
All three of them came to
independent conclusions.
And they said this kind of
research needs to be regulated
by an independent agency like
the Nuclear Regulatory Agency.
So for example, if
you're making centrifuges
in your basement in Miami,
you're not allowed
to sell them to Iran.
- Is that right, guys?
We're gonna have to,
- Yeah.
And as much as I'm not for
a lot of government rules,
I am for that.
That's for national security.
You shouldn't be able to
make, you know, atomic weapons
and sell them to people, you
know, or make the ingredients.
- Every libertarian
has their limit.
We just got you. 'Cause you
can't build your own nukes.
- Okay.
- That's my arms limit.
But I would have the same
kind of limits on DNA.
If we make DNA synthesizers
and you can create a virus out
of, just the particles of it.
So it really is there,
and a virus can't
survive without a host.
But really, they
can create life now.
We can create any
virus we want to
and they can put it together,
put the parts together
and then all it has to do
is enter into a
cell and it's alive.
It takes over the cell and
uses the cell to be alive.
But we create them
out of nothing.
And all you need is the map.
And so, we should
be regulating that,
the machines that do it,
the machines that help them
to recombine the virus and
maybe some of the animals.
So, we have these bizarre things
these hybrid animals
that are camaric animals.
They have mice that
have human lungs.
So what you do is,
you put a batch
of virus in there
that doesn't infect
humans really well.
And you put it in and
almost all of it dies
but a little bit of it lives.
And then you run it
through again and again,
serial passage until it
adapts to the human lungs.
And you're like, oh hey,
we made this virus that
doesn't infect humans.
We select it out by
pushing evolution.
Evolution could randomly,
something switches and
becomes infected human.
It's unlikely,
but it can happen.
This way, you force it to evolve
by continuing to run it through
human lungs that are in mice,
you can force it to evolve
in a direction to make it
more adaptable to humans.
And that's what people think.
This thing came out of
the lab and it boom,
it was incredibly
infectious to humans.
One of the strongest arguments
is, it won't affect bats.
We can't find an animal that
is a native host to this.
And they think almost all of
the coronavirus come from bats.
Well how did this thing
get so distant from bats
so quickly without us seeing it
somewhere else in the population
for a year smoldering?
Nobody has antibodies
to this till boom,
2020 then everybody gets it.
- Basically you're
giving me the beginning
of the zombie movie, right?
That's where this
whole thing goes.
- Essentially.
Realize, the world
went nuts completely.
Mostly Democrat governors
but even Republicans
went nuts on this thing.
Look at that, beating the
crap outta people in China,
locking people in their homes.
This death rate was
0.3% in the end.
It wasn't nothing, it wasn't
nothing to sneeze at, but 0.3%.
There are viruses that
they're monkeying around with
and at 15, 30%,
even 50% mortality
where half the world would die.
Can you imagine the freak out
when one gets out of a lab
that has a 50% mortality?
- What were you doing
in Kentucky like
that first two weeks?
'Cause I always say on my show,
I grant everybody sort
of a complete leash
for those first two
weeks when we had no idea
what was going on.
And even DeSantis,
who really came
out as the hero of this thing
he did lock down in essence for
two weeks and then reversed.
But as, as the liberty
guy, what were you doing?
And what kind of
pressure did you get?
- I never favored the lockdowns
and I didn't vote
for any of the money.
I didn't vote for one
penny of the COVID money
because I always
thought the choice was,
the Republicans said, well
for shutting down the economy
we have to give people money.
We can't just do that.
And I said well, maybe
we could reconsider
shutting down the economy.
So, I never was in
favor of the lockdowns.
And I, you know had
hoped that maybe,
Trump would do it temporarily.
But Trump succumbed as much
as he was portrayed
as a strong character,
he never fired Fauci.
And his people kept
saying, if you fire him,
you'll lose the election.
Well, he lost the election
and didn't fire Fauci.
Maybe he should have
fired Fauci early on.
And Fauci, Burke's,
they were all, you know
big government people
with decisions.
Every day, they had
a different opinion.
Almost none of it
was based on science.
And still to this day,
they won't acknowledge that
natural immunity works.
If you've had the infection,
you have some protection.
This isn't to deny
vaccines. They both work.
Vaccines work and so
does natural immunity.
And actually, the
combination of it,
it's why people aren't as
afraid of this disease anymore.
But it's also why is they
start to mandate COVID vaccine
on children that we should say,
well hey my kid
already had COVID.
Does he really need
a COVID vaccine?
Shouldn't I get that choice?
And the question I keep asking
if my kids already had COVID,
what is the chance that he
goes to the hospital and dies
with a second round of COVID?
It's probably zero.
In fact, I haven't seen a
case where a kid had COVID,
unless the child is very, very
sick from some other disease.
And almost all the
children that died under 18
were very, very sick and sadly
were dying from
some other disease.
There was nobody, there were
no like healthy children.
Like oh my, you know,
healthy 10 year olds
playing in the yard
gets COVID and die.
It didn't happen.
And so, we shouldn't be
forcing the vaccine on them.
Particularly because there are
some side effects to the
vaccine for children,
particularly boys between
the ages of 16 and 24
which just happened to be a lot
of the kids in our military,
the young men in our military
are at risk for a
heart inflammation.
And that risk exceeds easily
their risk for any kind
of problem from COVID.
- And then of course
Dr. Ladapo in Florida,
the Surgeon General
puts out that report
and then Twitter censors it,
which is a whole other
thing about censorship.
But I know you're tight on time.
So, let me just ask
you one other thing.
So, as we're taping
this on Tuesday,
supposedly Trump may make some
sort of announcement tonight.
Obviously the big thing right
now in the Republican party is
which way is this
thing gonna go?
Is it gonna be a Trump party
or perhaps a DeSantis party?
I know you, you founded one
with the Liberty Caucus, right,
with with Ron DeSantis?
- Early on, we were
allies up here.
I knew him something from the
congressional baseball game.
He was a good baseball
player. He played at Yale.
And I can remember him coming
to one of the early practices
and hitting home run in
practice, which is, you know,
for a bunch of old
guys out there playing,
it was pretty impressive.
- [Dave] Yeah. Yeah.
- So, he was a good player.
But he ended up having
shoulder surgery at that time
and didn't really
play on the team.
And then he ran for governor.
So, I don't know him real
well, but I have met him.
I've been impressed
with what he's done.
The other thing is,
it is about who you hire
in your administration.
The fact that he's put forward
this public health doctor
who is telling it like it
is and telling the truth
and is not just an
apologist for big government
and unafraid such that
he's got big tech alarmed,
I'm pretty impressed with that.
- What would you
want to happen there?
I'm not asking you for
who do you like more.
But in terms of,
do you want them,
if it's gonna happen, to
battle it out publicly
or would you rather it sort
of, be dealt with privately?
'Cause there's
just so many fights
it seems like right now
in the Republican Party.
- It's funny how people
come to politics like,
well why don't you just step
aside Dave and I'll do it.
And or you come to me and say,
well, you know, I
would be better at the
center of Kentucky.
Why don't you just step aside
and you can sort of
give me some advice.
No one ever does that.
- Yeah.
- So it never really
works behind the scenes.
So, what happens is, if
people have it inside them
and people in politics
aren't Shrinking Violets.
They believe they have
some of the answers,
and I think Trump would
fall into that category,
I think DeSantis would
I think there's a
half dozen others.
If I had to guess, and
this is just a guess,
I think today Trump's
going to announce,
that's probably not
as fairly easy guess.
And then, I think that
at some point in time
DeSantis will announce as well.
But I think once there's two,
then I think it'll be hard to
hold back some of the others.
I think there'll be a Pence,
I think there'll be
a Pompeo, you know.
They've all said they
wouldn't run against Trump.
- Getting back in the mix.
- I don't know.
But I do think that there
will be a mix though.
And for me, the
decision will be on,
who is the least likely
to get us involved in war.
A lot of them will be
fiscally conservative.
Some of them I
think are, you know,
much more inclined to be
involved in foreign war,
much more aggressive.
I mean, they'd send my
kids to Ukraine tomorrow,
most of them.
And I think Trump a
little less actually.
And Trump leans a
little more independent
or libertarian on the war issue.
And that used to be something
that could bring new
people into the fold.
But now the progressives
in our country
are more hyped up on
going to war in Ukraine
than just about
anybody in the world.
I mean, they really
are ready to,
they're not ready
to fight themselves,
but they're sure ready to
send your kid to Ukraine.
And the fact that we already
have soldiers in Ukraine
and nobody's really
talking about it,
just sort of silently happened.
Oh, they're just advisors.
They're just
counting the weapons.
They're there to have oversight.
You know, it's like,
yeah, until one of them killed
or a couple of them are killed
and then we're in the war.
- Plus the blank check
that you tried to
get some receipts on.
We'll keep waiting
for those receipts.
Senator, I appreciate your time.
- Thank you.
- Thanks.
If you're looking
for more honest
and thoughtful
conversations about politics
instead of nonstop yelling,
check out our politics playlist.
And if you wanna
watch full interviews
on a variety of topics,
watch our full episode
playlist all right over here.
And to get notified
of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.